as a grand well thank you very much d
now for the invitation thank you use it
for considering me I don't think Libyan
subject matter is well rooted in the
American Academy perhaps this is the
University which is something of an
exception but so that when I wrote was a
bit more long-winded and a bit more
subconscious than it might be if I felt
the never certain appealing to some
research everybody would agree on or
everybody would perhaps at least be
familiar with the perspectives that
someone might have so what I thought I'd
do in light of the condensation of time
is make it beginning introduce what my
main areas are and if these are of
interest then I'm happy to sort of
elaborate them in the discussion so I
introduce myself I'm a historian has
spent a good deal of time in Egypt since
the late 60s twice i was able to work in
libya and the seventies a guest of the
libyan study center
directed by the young doctor my mature
re as a historian I've always been a bit
frustrated by the way that the history
of these two countries has been written
and I believe it influences the strategy
of being adopted by people than the
who's who we read about today in current
events so I called my paper let me in
Egypt historical background to the
contemporary moment another and so using
the opportunity of the contemporary
moment to talk critically about history
my perception is that the history as
it's written about Lydia and also about
Egypt it's frozen conceptually in the
colonial past so I come to this
evening's events thinking perhaps we're
living in a moment which might
occurrence of rethinking of the past
because of the unexpected nature of
these current events and however one
might want to choose to go about it to
better address the question of how did
this past lead up to this present which
I
conditions as paradoxical perhaps in
other words the goal ought to be to be
able to think of some kind of approach
to Libyan history which would be useful
to the people who are currently for
testing autocracy and the same with
Egypt so when I'm assuming from the
outset is that much of this talk of work
produced about these two countries
remains in the case of Egypt in the
framework oriental despotism and in the
framework of Libya that Libya is not a
real state and as a result for reasons
I'm going to explain that maybe not
explained but would explain were you to
ask me to explain it contributes very
little to the present day needs in the
case in both countries with one
typically can find our council becoming
in the West and thereafter attempts on
the part of Europeans to make a nation
state that the foreman manner that they
find appealing to their sensibilities
following independence the Europeans
depart and then failure follows failure
more than one historian notes in passing
that the subject matter is difficult it
does not make a great deal of sense and
this is what I'm calling colonial
history whether it's written in English
Italian French or even Arabic why people
choose to continue to write history this
way since he never gets subject and it's
alright perhaps more significant that
the one I set for myself for this
evening
really know why they do in any case I'd
be interested to hear anyone's views on
this subject the subject aside for this
evening however it is what attempting to
sort of think in terms of what would
have to do to make these histories a bit
more relevant and I want to do this
without privileges to countries
experiences even though they're at the
forefront of today's news my sense is
that they share a great deal with other
countries and that they've suffered too
much from notions of exceptionalism in
the past and I don't either one spend
evening criticizing the works of
colleagues as I'm quite aware of how
difficult the conditions are working in
these countries or either people who
live there all the time or people who
try to come and work with us as
outsiders to decolonize the history of
these countries i use this word in
strong preference to post-colonial or
other notions to decolonize mr. these
two countries which is a bonus the term
you could hear in Libya the seventies
anyway my surmise is that in both cases
there would need to be a major overhaul
of the theorization of modern history
I go so far as to suggest that this
could be achieved it might very well
turn out to be the key to connect this
history the useful way to more recent
developments as I live up to this point
most of living history in a great deal
of Egyptian history is the story of
European actors the periodization we
make use of emphasizes what they did in
and so perhaps inadvertently perhaps not
with turn Libyans and Egyptians in many
cases or at least the mass population
and dis spectators over on history I'm
aware of the fact that pursuing the
direction I'm suggesting we pursue that
is focusing on the internal logic of the
local ruler rule that the larger numbers
of people and and the matching their
historical agency opens up some quite
unpleasant subjects dr. Ali or would he
suggested one and he is among those who
has taken the lead and trying to do this
in this country as for example once
Libya that Egyptian subject Egyptians
become the subject of their own history
all kinds of subjects come out of the
woodwork in the Libyan case we have to
come to grips with what you said to
recall that betimes killed a very
significant percentage of the entire
population and then you could add to
this the Americans came along to front
of the oil and while there's some need
to cover this all
this might be part of the explanation
for why the field is prevented from
decolonizing is doubtless more to it
than that I think however not just for
scientific reasons but politically
speaking as the planet's resources keep
shrinking and as the future draws us
closer together as a result of that fact
a country survival may well change a
more realistic knowledge of itself for
better or for worse and this would trump
any short-term benefit of saving face I
make the same point to the
postmodernists in this country and
exactly the same criticism many of them
seem to want to defend the United States
by getting a subject of the Iraqi
national history or Guantanamo or
Afghanistan's national history off the
radar screen perhaps to shield America's
reputation by ruling out history is
approach to knowledge however I think
it's too late in human history for this
to be a good idea either so it is not
simply the problems of Libyan and
Egyptian studies I think this is a wider
Tennessee of an empire of decline in
some sense is to run away from the study
of history
columbia being famous in terms of the
development of the studies of american
studies of American history this seems
to be a place where I'm hoping for a
good round of applause right this
confirms the stereotype I wanted to have
confirmed the question I've seen also
men can and this would apply to our
country here not going to be likes
historians going through with archives
but historians have been pretty good at
making the case that the likely benefits
more than outweigh the negative
potentiality historians have been doing
this for a while they can do it again at
Libya the individual i mentioned
mohammed ur re can do this in Egypt
historians like osomatsu V can do this
and it seems perfectly logical to me to
make this as an argument that and the
priority that knowledge of national
history creates a level of self
understanding that's indispensable for
society which has to even in the short
term compete internationally nevermind
what will come in the long term although
certainly the bag of study history is
much greater than simply our fears about
the future now proceeding from these
assumptions I'm going to turn to the
theme
thinking or rethinking the historical
background of the present moment and I
want to do so emphasizing two areas
which I think stand in need of revision
and one being from the early modern
period at one being from the modern
period and then I had intended by way of
conclusion to sort of then link what I
had to say to the current events but as
time will permit I think boo boo I will
blunder on into the subject of early
modern history is it not a subject which
is familiar even to students who spent a
good deal of time and that there are
very few books on the period of Libyan
history 16th 17th 18th century a few
basically in Arabic and a cursory
treatments in English however as a
general principle if you study the
history of a variety of different
countries you would find that the more
developed that historiographical
tradition becomes the more likely it is
that historians discover a link between
the early modern period and the modern
period in terms of their discussions of
modernity in other words it's more a
function of the development of the
history
fashion that it is some unique feature
of the country itself this can be shown
in about 20 or 30 or 40 cases right now
in the world and these are the places
where historians have been privileged to
work in the systematic way so I'm
assuming were Libyan studies to be
elevated and got out of the sort of
marginal position discoveries of the
store could be produced what we do now
know is from work done on North Africa
in general a little Olivia some on Egypt
is that in the early modern period the
Arab world including North Africa was a
collection of city-states and
agricultural hinterlands bound together
often through trade routes sameera mean
called this the Arab nation the Ottoman
Empire Istanbul which has receives a
much attention what in Villistas was for
the most part quite remote its personnel
however often basically soldiers of
fortune blended into the country's I'm
referring to that they were sent to and
so the word Ottoman it gets used quite a
bit in our studies where it would be
more precise for us to use the word X
ottoman that term I've never heard use
but I think it
a better term I now move to try to sort
of pursue that sameer means description
and refer to the the world as a whole
that's the course of jagged on a look at
picked up in her book the was sort of an
archipelago of city-states along the
trade routes and the Arab world is
famous for this all we can say at the
moment is that the trajectory of this
archipelago is different than the
trajector the one who are familiar with
starting out in Renaissance Europe both
had cities along trade routes but in the
case of Europe when nemesis is that the
trade routes bypassed large parts of
Europe which were not so commercialized
your pet highly capitalized places and
these were very commercial and they had
feudal back waters all over whereas in
the Arab world virtually all the cities
were connected with with merchants and
merchants and artisans were a dominant
force these differences a reflected in
language development and I believe also
literature development the Europeans
involved separate national languages
which all shared a common base in Latin
well in the Arab world kept evolving a
common language and a kind of prodean
arabism which would go with it one could
attribute this here to repeat to the
more homogeneous ly commercial economies
of the Arab cities another general
feature of
early modern times
you're doing okay command that EA you've
got back in another generalized feature
of the early modern period which I
believe is so general that one should
apply to here as well and I get this
from the book I wrote rise of the rich
which was my vase adventure in prison
sorry it wasn't is that the early modern
political economy was mercantilist in
other words it was ace economic strategy
which took a variety of political forms
around the world to allow for a certain
amount of international trade while
protecting the home market and the
political stability of the concert and
in fact these possession regimes or
systems were common throughout the Arab
world and we know them best from
economic history but I think in terms of
hoarding money in terms of of the
enclosing markets but basically I think
one should move quickly from the
economic to the political and note that
the the roots of modern history came out
of the struggles in different kinds of
mercantilist regimes imperative mortal
writing points in that way so that a
variety of systems each with their
Pirates and their markets which could
keep foreigners out
and here you would include Libya were
the common feature of early modern
chives a book by Peter landlord Wilson
talks a little about that the
commonality of the early modern period
and this was here to repeat a general
trend so what I'm saying I believe would
apply what we know to Libya and Egypt
that is Libya Egypt should be regarded
as as mainstream history as France or
Italy or Spain in this timeframe
specific ideas about the client
isolation stagnation so often applied to
the study of Arab countries seem to me
to be simply Apriori bad judgments where
they did more to the rise of the West
paradigm that took any specific
knowledge but I I think that the thing
to say to scholars who use these is that
it's your obligation to say what a
country is and not what you think it
isn't but what if you think it's lacking
so I believe this would be the place to
look for the origins of Libyan modernity
and and i miss i think that the rise and
decline of mercantilism is the biggest
event in for centuries in libya history
and its related basically to the sinner
sees who basically they're coming
greater prominence of a certain period
change the political equilibrium and
what is known is that libyan
were famous internationally and they are
called McDermott and you saw a great
deal of evidence of them in Egypt and
increasingly we know a bit about the
trade routes that they followed and so
on and so if we can study it seems to me
Genoa and Italian merchants after the
Renaissance and so forth studying the
Libyan material is not doesn't show it
going to be any more stranger or or
difficult for us to do it's a question
of going more deeply into our own
psychology about what it is about Libya
that has made Libya invisible force in
other words what do we gain culturally
psychologically over the long term by
not having Libya as part of our service
psychological map that's the more
complicated question so part two as we
arrived at the 19th century Egypt and
Libya become more distinct from one
another on a political level now rush
into this as if this was too late when
Libya still managed to keep the old
trade routes functioning and the
Europeans were kept out for kept
somewhat marginal in Egypt it was the
reverse in the crucial period 1780 1815
as I wrote about it in Islamic works
what happened was that the Egyptian more
art classes entered into the European
markets buying its luxury does coming to
depend on it
exporting their own raw goods that early
been crucial to their own urban
artisanal economy as this was taking
place the country became divided in a
new way from a set up of different
centers each of the distance from one
another Cairo being premise into Paris
this was the old system called san jac
source in attic and this was the setup
in Libya and many other quizzes a new
system arose one giving some weight some
measure of hegemony two more cat was
north of the country over more fuel
south of the country Cara becoming the
midpoint between these two regions the
north of her south form a rule which was
then a parent was to deepen over the
years a point I'm going to return to
when I talked about the multi the thugs
and the Egyptian police they're the
regional question which emerges in this
period 1780 1815 comes to the surface
that explains the curious relationship
between me dammit a career and the lower
levels of the Egyptian police
now coming up to the era of colonialism
it is perhaps something up almost of a
distraction that in Libya assistant
prevailing which was one as I told you
of regions of plans of extended familial
groupings had superimposed on it an
Italian idea of central state and where
if there was going to be in fact a kind
of common denominator in all this the
gender question was starting to emerge
or gender and class were starting to
emerge but in a certain sort of sense
this was not the Italian approach and so
first Ottomans and then entire was
trying to oppose the central authority
the heart of they tried the more insane
it was in conclusion i'll try to connect
this point of insanity or erratic
behavior to the mama of two laughing
today and the scent centralism in other
words i think that some of what we call
the crazy nipples up to that he could be
interpreted and a kind of historical
structural sense i don't think it can be
made in the sort of narrow psychological
sense of an individual
really taking power this might be some
component of it but I think there's
different kinds of insanity and the
behavior and the sort of
disconnectedness of this individual what
I think you see are some of the
structural contradictions which go with
attempting centralism in a context in
which the logic of a society because
that sort of centralism so I now would
say in Egypt the British gave up
basically their idea that they had an
oriental despotism in place with the
breakdown on the protector and the
coming of 1923 Constitution which for
then reluctantly sort of pointed the way
to the road departure now to conclude
this section on rethinking the origins
of modernity it's important to recall
once more what I challenged it to make
living history Libyan what has to
challenge the idea of the coming of the
west and then one has to challenge what
is normally considered to be a modern
form of state that is the western form
of state which is taken to be a
particular form of state and these are
all really very primitive ideas rooted
in wanting to attributes of what are
taken to be States without reference to
the way in which stratification in other
words to understand deeply what a state
is you have to understand how two rulers
keep all the wealth and play for people
against each other and basically destroy
the middle class this strategy of what's
called maintaining stratification is the
way in which you tell what a Germany is
to say their elections or a constitution
or laws or no laws doesn't tell you
really a great deal it's how do a few
people managed to keep power and wealth
and how do they manage to keep poor
people basically at each other's throats
so basically when we're talking about a
discussion of modernity tribal ethnic
States which is the word in political
anthropology for better or worse is in
form of modern hegemony parallel to that
of the United States which is of course
for democracy in other words as a
structure it works like our structure
works in other words we can keep poor
people in this company it played off
against each other and this stabilized
as well so we have a stable system and
many other countries of the world do as
well and but historians back here for
historians in between the Western
countries maintained that only country's
shaped like the United States in other
words with structural racism our modern
in tribal trouble ethics days or kick
main states they associate with weak
states even though the term weak state
really doesn't mean anything and with
primitivism a term which also doesn't
mean anything or with not state another
term which doesn't mean anything well in
any case whatever it they're using it
these are opposites to the notion of
what is called modern state in other
words take the state form that there
must familiarize this is where living
studies has to sort of become somehow
develop the skills will be able to argue
with this look at what we know is that
the decentralization found internal
ethic States appears to threaten people
in countries like our own for the norm
is the centralized state now is it
because of the genocide of the
indigenous population which were also
this sort who's to say but direct
democracy or deciding for oneself as
opposed to electrical electoral
democracy voting for someone to decide
for you perhaps even creates for
scholars a certain amount of cognitive
distance and they can't control
themselves this too is an interesting
psychological problem I can't control my
phone too much longer I think I'm gonna
have to ask you to wrap it up penguin
not my first such experience